2019 World Finals and we are getting
started with Pool D the last pool where
we're gonna find out which two players
will be getting to our top eight which
will be happening immediately after so
I'm excited to see this I'm here with
spaghetti rap my name is Mark man that's
my man how's it going how's it going I
dare say we've left the best for lost
yeah messy commentary the best group I'm
excited to see this of course you guys
can see what we're looking at Pool D we
have from Pakistan oh hi sunny from
South Korea chanel from the US of A
Jimmy J Tran from Japan no B and low
high from South Korea man that is quite
the variety and also pipe the level of
high level sail players on another day
this could have been the top five of the
actual tournament oh yeah I thought of
the finals it's crazy what a strong
group I mean I cannot I cannot hold
who's gonna get out of this group I mean
I can make predictions but I don't want
to do it just because I don't want to
live like I don't know what I'm talking
about
cuz that's already out there anyway this
match the first match oh oh god we have
low I going up against no B oh this is
crazy water first match you won't you
slow - Sam Arsenault beat Japan mr.
Korea and I look low hi is someone who I
feel like I just leveled up so
drastically this year to the point where
I even said that I felt like he was the
best in the Korea you know next to me or
one of the best players in the world I
when I was in Korea he won three
tournaments in a single week yeah guys
so good right now he's been playing
non-stop Tech and he says to me all I do
is I wake up I wake up I play Tekken
gotta go to sleep that's the kind of
grinding me to do in order to be at the
top level he has ascended though he has
gone to another level and right now
we're gonna see how it's gonna play of
course no be a legend or has you know
he's been that I think every single
World Finals since we started the
technical world tour as well but no be
back here again it is the battle that we
expected it is Shaheen versus dragon boy
oh and we're seeing the red beret with
the goggles night vision we might be
going downstairs into the dark talking
about that best precess fighter
we mediate lo Perry here we go no hi now
you know I was talking to me last night
he said he was explaining to me the
differences in the style between
American European Japanese and Korean
and he when he got to know me he said
you know nobody has his own style oh
yeah the whole style yeah and it
obviously works out from you know right
now especially with a lot of eyes off
dragon have a lot of people thinking you
know this probably the best interation
since you know maybe season 1 hmm sure
nice gets the counter hit and the
follow-up here that is Chuck I got to
talk about Lola though lohi is one of
those players if you guys are unfamiliar
with the former Evo champion flood also
on top of that he has probably some of
the best reflexes in the game yeah for
sure and it's just the only way you get
that is by playing so much Tekken you
know he's been doing nothing but first
round to know be here in legend for a
reason
oh there's a punish there I'm not sure
if that's what he wanted there with the
snake 3 but having an opportunity back
to the wall he's gonna have to be very
very careful at how he's gonna go about
this yeah every match in this group is
gonna be a lot much got to play the best
second of your life if you want to get
out of ass oh in the night step here
he's gonna get faced down to the floor
put an icy bait there from Nobby oh my
god chopping over to the tattoos I go
through another load gonna be two rounds
up here they'll be super calculated here
he is a make things count here yeah I'm
sure we've broken 84 kids lately but
what one yeah it was a bad memory for
bigots it oh we're going down again to
the bottom floor here should be able to
find the boy especially receives either
one yeah mrs. put their vote for the
cancel unable to get it with the sandy
three but got the slide instead and look
at this she has a huge lead what is
going on here no be putting hands on low
high like it's nobody's business
no my student Oh guess they put the
second of the race drivers I'm gonna be
deaf maybe very close one more hit could
do it here
caught jab into range driving you know
no be the master of that running attack
running to so good angled buffs in
season three as well
doesn't matter low high what is he gonna
do him you want is a thick machine I'm
sure yeah he's gonna go to stage two
like here we're gonna find out where we
need is he gonna pick the stage is he
gonna go for the Korean classic an open
stage baby yeah you might go for the
upper stage looks like he's hovering on
infinite as ooh it opened up his stick
now no interesting okay Kazu okay here
we go and I when I was in Korea they
were telling me that you know the
Koreans would some people they like to
go to infinite stage when they think
they're fundamentally stronger than
their opponent because then it's just
pure Tekken at that point there isn't
gonna be any weird moves flat sidewalk
you know a lot we've already seen this
weekend some Redux wacky stuff with the
world yeah but this is pure attacker
right here I think for the most part a
lot of people pink no wall save you just
because you don't want to risk the
potential damage that there they'll have
more chances to make mistakes they'll
have more chances to live if they get
hit by combos yes so it really is like
you mentioned it is all about your
fundamentals and being able to out play
in the open yes
and obviously that doesn't change there
are no walls man if you get into a wall
over here man you you found one more
than I could no be right now let's see
if he's able to continue this momentum
yes there we go finally poking it down
to oh it's too early for that no be back
swing right away the Farlow puts him
into rage now he has an opportunity one
he could do it oh my gosh you wimp
I'm gonna hang out with but low high
here and he got a combo double tailspin
there we go it's about even on life but
now dragon arm having raised Oh double
Oh Jeff I can't believe it that trade
unfortunate there for long I did not
have enough life
jeez yeah thank God for the save option
I just had that chance to paint feeling
where my arm got ripped off trouble from
this home the tastes team yeah man watch
out for that guy
get down to a chomping away bucket
system out poke in it right now
Roy no bee is playing like a man
possessed you know like I said no be not
a stranger to the world stage but you
know it's been a while since he's been
able to place and the higher are the
branch a lot I would say yes it has
another opportunity for low high let's
see if you can break the momentum you
deputies to get around here same problem
as last time he put some in to raise
what's he gonna do now got the raise
drive once again to pour two down on the
range drive go beyond set point a to O
start for nobody would be perfect yeah
it'll be quite the exclamation point
here to start off pool D but right now I
mean low heights gonna have to fight
back we were just talking about how he
has great review plexus but no bee has
had an amazing reads to just how play is
about a half game experience now he's
mentioned he's been on the world stage
so many times know how though not a
stranger to the situation and just the
way that players are able to adapt you
know no visa always has to constantly
deal with this reinventing his self
reinventing his character we see
enraging it this is where he's dangerous
he is one in rate so many time but the
throw did not break in that time yeah
no break in low heart finally break in
the momentum guess around on the port
but those down to still chopping away
he's not dealing with those those walks
that seems to be a problem for an old
gets the counter hit the follow up here
and right now low high trying to rush
him down but still about even on life
yes there'll be still mounting the
pressure was very very close range
checking a good block on the down to
finally get the punish April to stop
some of that momentum it pushes them
away gets the hop kick easy to seal the
deal here we're going to final round
here match number two low high chance
here to tie it up and this is something
he wants he wants to be able to win the
set yes it's very important get these
matches on the point looking for the
reverse we've had low high three runs
straight can you do it okay again going
Adam with the throws here again low my
able to break a blue man he has to be
careful here again don't be not afraid
to use that down to you're not gonna
steal away his move some of his favorite
was running two down two that's always
gonna come out yes so much confidence
you can tell you this pace out right now
hold on is TV go for the shoulder
wrong punish there from no beware even
on health right hand I sidestep oh I
thought he was sideways enough to goes
for the full string unable to get in
here nice break range available raise
drive from low high but he's not gonna
be able to use that as low B will take
out low height to 200 perfect stock top
when he got that second down to God the
win he is obviously feeling himself
that's a great start for know B and for
Japan here in Pool D look he is he's
really good he's loving it he's feeling
good but he's gonna go back and sit down
as we get more of our matches up but man
that was crazy that was really crazy
especially considering how strong Lowe
has been all season man he's been
winning so I can't even count on my
hands how many report of us this guy's
won like it's crazy
constantly been playing are the
tournaments or going to offline sessions
yeah I Reno off Ryan sessions don't even
happen anymore in Korea but this guy
wants to play a fine even but gathers
people together and you plays
I mean practicing really hard for this
but Wow Dobby still showing why he's a
legend have you guys have a look at the
group's standings at the moment shinobi
of course we just had the one match but
now we can have Chanel Jimmy J turn it
away honey
yet to play oh and I think the next
matchup we have and I see him getting -
sage we got the birthday boy rocks
dragon Chanel shooting rock paper
scissors right now with genuine gaming
so wise honey so Pakistan vs. South
Korea this is a match that a lot of
people have been looking forward to not
just the player matchup but just to see
what a white honey can do in this
tournament yes that the the hopes of
Pakistan now rest on a west
Hani's show there is the last remaining
Pakistani in this tournament belong or
not are out with Chanel man you know
what you know before this well to start
assaulted someone asked me who do you
think is gonna win this all well - and I
said you know what I think Chanel has
been such a strong player and he's
another one that has been you know at
the world stage yeah year in year out
every single you're even dating back to
the king of Iron Fist tournament series
right he's always been there placing
very well in the topping last year you
got top heat as well
yeah but when tis time once he gonna win
a big turn that's the question because
how many times has this man got second
place yeah so many times and I was just
thinking to myself that it has to have I
gotta ask you a question like who would
you say it's probably the most dangerous
man in second I think a lot of people
would say knee right his training
partner is Janelle there you go
to be equally as dangerous he is man I
mean you can see it how many times you
just like you mentioned he places high
all the time he's just never able to get
over that barrier way he's winning a
tournament it sounded kind of the same
as Kakuma right but I was thinking to
myself surely yeah his time has to come
soon
oh yeah and right now before we get into
the matchup we're gonna he see some
words here from a white honey but I play
the king of fighters but in Pakistan the
taken community is called the end of
chaos so I decided to play the taken
because I like the game too much
everybody wants to take and take and
take an impact on so that's why I chose
taken awesome not to mention nice
Pakistan the two main games K reckon
second they're crazy about these games
Mark Mandy's Pakistan going down there
earlier this year was was really really
a treat to be able to see the passion
these guys have but aware honey man he
was the man that brought Akuma to the
Pakistani shows he's the one that taught
everyone how to use the character when
he went it wasn't even like he's from
Lahore he's from the city where all the
top players are from he actually went
away from Lahore to another city called
fest LaVon and that's where he learned
how to play Akuma really he learned it
from the arcades invest labott and then
he took that information brought to the
[ __ ] and he said hey I do I have
something for you guys
oh it's Chanel oh thank is that giving
us some kind of indication of which
character he's going to be using I mean
it better if he doesn't pick a subpoena
now then I'm gonna be upset I'm hungry
ELISA faded but he can do what he wants
he knows the matchups he knows what he's
getting himself into I gotta say though
one of the storylines here at least
during the Tekken World Tour at least
the latter half of the year is not only
Pakistan but also the strength of Akuma
yes out of Pakistan and we saw at the
master event in Tokyo Tech and masters
how dominating they were and always
honey really Cigna kind of like that's
where he clinched a berth into the
technical world tour from this event yes
yes
the FB Cup in Malaysian and Tokyo tekken
masters these guys been performing so
well but hair is where it counts the
finals Tekken World Tour final 2019 the
first match for both the gentlemen there
we go Korea vs. Pakistan check now vs
away honey
yeah she don't wanna this run back of
course he said he remembers the Dubai
event he wants to be able to fight the
demon so to speak a man that was such a
closed set as well claimed that - 150 50
in the end so I'll expected the same
hair nice both of these players
jockeying for position right now oh wise
honey again he's been waiting the entire
day to play his pool now finally here we
get to see this cooler master in action
wow he knew exactly when to go for that
gap gets the Dragon Punch yeah the TP
right over that chainsaw stops he's been
using a lot of that forward forward
right kick they're in conjunction with
the homie move as well trying to really
create some pressure moments here and
this is where it's important cuz do you
have to control the match especially
when you don't have that meter and still
be offensive at the same time mindful
enough to be able to fill that meter
along along the way I know I'm just
gonna say nice Chanel his biggest
strength is his natural movement he's
able to sidestep better than most most
people in the world is crazy of course
ELISA and subpoena bonus characters do
have really really good movement anyway
but he utilizes it so well nice kills
the punish here and the knockdown it's
gonna have to be careful there right in
the middle of the stage here but I
wouldn't be so my gosh gets the launch
back turn there with the downpour - one
now what's he gonna do here what's the
big stuff he was going for some dirty
stuff there I've seen that before
yeah use the homie move trying to stop
[ __ ] out from sidestepping trying to
discourage him heavy dog goes for the
town wall started to intervene flip nice
get the float here you should be able to
get the wall you might be able to close
it out once the oh yeah very close
ohit's goes for the mid nice race honey
on the board all right there tied up on
rounds here match number one of course
if you guys are tuning in let every no
twitch.tv slash tech in tell everyone
man oh yeah tell your mom your dad you
grab that everyone
there's a follow-up he's able to get the
focus and he should get the wall here
light them up
oh I feel good see that's a crazy mix-up
too cuz you mean you stay there he could
Rhys Platt you right yeah
but then if you get up too soon that
while standing - is gonna float you
anyways and there you go should now
trying to float the theme of it which is
not a good option especially when he
knows how to deal with that he has
multiple options to beat the jab Oh such
a great move they're able to make sure
he gets the hit down Ford one two for
the win and the Weiss honey yeah he's
been using a lot of [ __ ] head but have
you go find it uses the load condition
Chanel not to duck and have you go
taking it to the wall all in he's gonna
get the fall up here real lines himself
gets the two hits of the street yeah she
don't doing a good job to stay on
through the girl doesn't wanna get hit
by any big stops nice punish that
could've got pulled on or the chain saws
round you gonna have to be careful you
don't want to get cut mm-hmm yeah and it
looks like Kuma's outfits already been
cut a few times yeah tattered all over
the place he's seen some bouts in his
time oh yeah again this pressure found
even online for these players bright in
the middle here nice back one and a low
parry beautiful have you go he's not
gonna be dead though you know we'll have
another chunk oh yes you will one week
some and there just goes for the simple
low attack sometimes I mean just because
you know most of Akuma's low attacks
kind of have that low-profile animation
that one is kind of tricky it's kind of
hard to see cuz he's doing it from the
standing position yes yes it was a wise
honey drawing for us but getting that
first match looks like Chanel content
with using Elysee is still in this
matchup he's gonna continue to use that
character but what stage are we going to
now
at this point money you know isn't the
cream classy
yes but this point you know he's got a
plan man and that's why he's gonna stick
with it I hope you know I respect it all
right so we are now going into an open
stage away Sonny man not only is
Pakistan an asylum I'm guessing most of
Australia is gonna be on this side as
well
the Aussies out there that be gonna be
on this side now let's go second match
what our quest oh yeah of course genuine
gaming based out of Australia I believe
right let's see how they're able to
utilize their cheering for their
champion rod I might miss God oh wise
honey all right nice oh and he goes for
a tone that he was trying to do some new
some I've not seen that before saving it
for the finals
yeah there's putt-putt with this one day
to do it today's the last day
yeah let it all hang out and he sit with
rage now what is that try to light him
up nice punish there from Chanel boy
Ranch Drive blue stuff let's go [ __ ] now
of the board to chanela man he's fully
equipped he has all the items on as well
that is what a waste is so good honest
the reason why he's been waiting toward
us is that standing to rent money shop
yeah he is quite the master when it
comes to you know just the natural
spacing with Akuma and optimizing
maximize meets combo potential and you
know he's one of the ones like I mean
everyone's dropping Akuma is like left
and right right yeah his consist he's
probably one of the highest out there
Akuma is not they make you talk Akuma is
a way Sony's bait now too depending the
playing him from the start I think
that's really why we see the consistency
more often from players like super
equipment of course oh I see yes
absolutely all right let's see this
happen what's he gonna do here still
trying to find this opening I mean
Chanel really hasn't had an opportunity
to take advantage of any of the budget
like it supplies it's huge and look at
this another big combo from Roy's honey
yeah a waste honey finding his range
they get into town 15 head if you're
wondering what clean it means it means
you have to be in close range in order
for that to actually combo and the West
funny is finding that close range this
time it wasn't yeah if you're too far
away and you go for the fireball Castle
you're not able to confirm it two more
combo damage it's just a waste of built
resources there yes okay nice block man
defect and aways honey fool one round
away from taking the piss verse match
two to nothing
oh nice able to get behind them sneak
attack with the cheats on the beat just
drop it and here we go the bank ones
successful the follow-up hearing going
for the mix-up what's he getting it all
man he tried to pick him up again yeah
but good patience again from Chanel but
he has a massive black deficit hair
always funny-looking dude at the moment
Kenshin I'll bring it back yeah and
right now all wise his frightening with
those bids and you know it's gonna be
quite the different story because you
would expect a low coming up especially
when he has the meat oh my god it's just
static that long and sometimes that's
the scariest thing you stare into the
eyes of the demon he doesn't take any
risks was I able to beat it out this is
huge to get a lot of damage it's not
gonna kill but he puts a bit to the rent
that was huge damage oh my god he had
him out of the air that time though it's
not over yet oh and the pop-up is well
[ __ ] no that's Janelle feeling himself
here the birthday boy I mean you gotta
have the confidence right you're gonna
go against one of the best players in
the world you have to make sure you feel
yourself and look at this ghost with the
reset that doubts you punish nice suck
but not quick enough to get the punish
444 me move everything seems to be
working for a wise one more he could do
it not over yet though nice it's a bunny
no way no way no way
oh no way is he gonna make this comeback
Oh mix-up time that was expected here's
a low yeah it goes for the throw
those were such a huge risk with upward
or they're obviously punished and a wise
let me make the point to 0 to 0 that's
that's now to players to have won 2-0
and their first match is no B and aways
for Chanel we're not getting the classic
tanking final round final badge today
are we trying to like speed things up
for topic maybe man that was not so we
that was a great match obviously we're
gonna go ahead and get our next match up
on stage I believe it's gonna be USA's
Jimmy J trot out of Northern California
and he's gonna be going up against Hamas
Adobe from Tokyo you know you think
about Jimmy is I feel like you know he
doesn't travel to as many tournaments
and other people but this Mac doesn't
meet to lucky so consists not
international he actually did travel
quite a bit this year you know we get in
the in the in the western region he went
to every single master of it right right
okay but I think we do have an update
here let's see where we're at man look
at the group right now yes
it's starting again you know this has
happened every single group that we've
seen so far you know it starts off nice
and smooth then it starts getting hectic
and then I just start pulling out my
hair but it's very easy to follow what's
going to right now know being away Sonya
I literally tied at the moment with two
and with one match each winning at 200
and Shannel in low high of course being
the victims of both of those guys Jimmy
J Tran there in the middle yes to place
first much but he is up on stage waiting
for his opponent I think yeah it's gonna
be the classic I mean they're gonna go
for the rock-paper-scissors they're
gonna find out which side is gonna go to
the I guess the advantage I mean you
know I know Jimmy always prefers one
player side but we'll see how that's
gonna play out was it was it a 20-17
final that Jimmy and OB played and then
wait they went at it yeah the finger
guns that was that hope it does I get
man Jimmy a few wins I know you can hear
me if you win you got to do the little
the finger good all the finger guns back
waving to the crowd of course we're
waiting for the match of course it's
gonna be happening in just a bit but man
if you guys have been tuning it's been a
fun-filled year of the Tekken World Tour
this is our final day I hope you guys
are excited because right now we are
whittling down to get towards our top
eight and of course all the action in
between now and then but I gotta give it
up man everybody that's been tuning and
twitch.tv slash Tekken yeah
and there's a lot of people restreaming
right now I mean I see shots all those
guys restream but I want to ask you more
cuz you've been in the second scene for
none other anyone and way longer than I
have how is it been to see the developer
of Tekken from from way back then - to
where it is now it's it's just a nice
feeling to see that this game realized
its potential I've always believed in
this game but now we're seeing it as one
of the games that has grown so much
year-over-year not just in viewership
not just in tournament entries but just
you know love for the game right and
it's a genuine good game that everyone
has grown to love and I like that I know
so many people now that are watching
Tekken and they're watching it at a
level where you know they may not be as
emotionally invested as a lot of other
people but they can respect the game and
they can let people know that hey Tekken
is one of the best fighting games if not
the best fighting game out there
absolutely man I agree 100% the heavy go
our players are up on stage know be from
Japan versus Jimmy J Tran and I believe
we have some words from Lobby by the
tournament okay taking the Japanese on
Pakistan operate by detect occurred on
your take I take anymore ninja stamina
Leone
yep arena today I'm at the epic octo
game another kinda taking a to
immortality little-known disc at all
[Applause]
yeah you are taking tomorrow even let's
create again mechanical for Boca Chica
undercut State the commode chair so it's
viewing today Duke you can see the only
thing better is onna no ko take a coda
seriani Grammatik say no - you know just
like just like margin above was telling
us yesterday man these guys are very
prideful and they you know they're very
passionate about the game just like he
said Tekken's origins are in Japan he's
not let's make Japan great again this
year they've already been playing at
such a high level like we haven't seen
before and you know we've already got
the Japanese representation in top eight
no be on his way to get there as well
yeah what's the meet up with double
double obviously qualified on the winner
side and I believe Chickering also
qualifying on the winner side is now
damn japan put in work here but yes to
go up against one of the best players in
the world here and one of the best in
America Jimmy J Tran I run back from the
previous finals yeah
can't nobody win it this time yeah those
guys ended a meeting up in pool play as
well and Jimmy getting the upper hand in
that one that was back in 2017 mm-hmm
but here we go deep breaths the
meditation the focus from both of these
players it's the matchup that we did
expect Brian fury versus dragon off here
we go let's do it
kinder Jim's not often that we see the
stage soak up the stage nice nice block
there surprised you didn't go for the
new punish there and the knockdown
Saturdays I think you'll hit he'll note
you'll realise he'll warm up into it
right yeah nice counter hit 1 2 1 and
right now no be controlling the spacing
at least on the stage with a big counter
shotgun bang is good and the big damage
as well
Brian it's very very hard heavy goes to
okey oh god no B I told you it's too
early for this he's that cat that raised
right Wow
that is not a movie Bob Irwin what did
you bid that could have been bad that
could have been very bad I be covered
but Wow
I think obviously you wanted running one
plus two but he just saw maybe miss
input just their pastor one position
stop running
all right gets the slighty okay no be
just continuing off where you left off
earlier when he had that nice matchup
but man he is playing out of his mind
even able to be low high now zerkin Gus
Jimmy J man the Pope's as well
utilizing at the perfect time as well
and that's the name two men this is
dragon on as far as I'm concerned no be
one of the best dragon our players of
all time
this is reminded me of Tekken 6 loving
that where he was just so dominant like
anyone here play against he would be
happy go another big launch head from
nothing go and he has the reads on read
right now he's doing such a great job
man wall the wall the hose and right now
Jimmy taking back some of that momentum
he really needs this he's gonna have to
be very careful at how he's gonna get
here we walk through this Junction he
has a sliver of life and it wasn't
enough that down to how many times has
he been able to hit that down to without
being challenged it's crazy nobody's
timing right now and his move choices
are impeccable
that is three without three rounds
strength that was three quick around
straight damn though be looking like a
piece right now what is Jimmy gonna do
on to the character select screen maybe
just take a little bit of time he's not
never gonna switch away from Brian he's
always one for Brian Harris taking some
time here just to think all right he has
the ability to pick a stage here of
course and he's gonna go to his favorite
it looks like G Corp helipad always
chooses to go that probably one of the
most creative stages in the game you
have polar wall you have walls on the
upside and stages here that are
breakable of course that leads to more
potential damage yeah and we've seen the
we've seen the compost he's been able to
do at this stage in tournament and
they're very very damaging so hopefully
because season regime is you see Jimmy
get some opportunities ever no be play
like a piece man we hear the USA chant
in the crowd
we go probably the the Thai community
thanks guys
both guys not great heads this as well
they can get so cute all that energy
have you got a second match don't be up
one oh nice one for able to do space
outside of the range they're nice tepid
kick but unable to get anything out of
Jimmy again starting to the sides I'm
starting to work some of his defensive
magic give me J such a methodical player
definitely took some time to think about
what he needs to do why did he use the
questions gosh so you know what it's all
these stuff we're talking about but you
know what you're just playing normal
second normal second alright let's see
what he does with the dough back to the
walls gonna have to be very careful here
does not want to get supplant I mean and
you know dragging off there's so many
more tools now that really increases the
danger of his wall game oh my God he's
going let him get up yeah H available
Jimmy J tried oh oh god no he's with the
pressure not anything's not letting him
get comfortable and that's the strength
I think Adobe is his ability to kind of
delay and use that down to in
conjunction with every other tool set
that nobody has and the down to solgryn
is all because it tracks the both sides
the heavy with the launch yeah get to
crouch s and he's getting a big use of
the wall here let's see what he does
stack o + frames huge laughs you
different OB Jimmy James Rahon does not
know what to do right now no B is on set
point once again - take it - oh it's
very it's 5 feet rounds this is this is
looking bad yeah he's gonna have to turn
things up here make some adjustments
there goes for the Mach kick unable to
get into the criminal good County hey
had just
momentum innovation he should yeah
decent come perhaps break the wall to
the next one
nice sidewall son able to still move
forward look at all that damage here
it's his round to lose it he's able to
get it Jimmy gchat drawing his first
round here in the set yes
is that what he needed just a little bit
momentum heavy go goes to the double
knees yeah second hit and again no be
still very confident but a nice tuck
there he knows that Jimmy J staying
attentive this could be big goes for the
running slashing no one's home it's okay
that he wasn't punished too hard for it
all but on the third here at the
straight know me all this damage range
event for town to to get this time the
perfect punish season three baby Jimmy J
time taking it to a final round yeah he
knows that sometimes you know the
tendencies of no bu likes to go for it's
multiple down to something down to
sidestep down to yeah but he's aware of
you off to a quick start again he is not
letting up the pressure doesn't confirm
the hit oh that was an opportunity you
trying to go for the top Jenna or the
Jennifer there ya know be one more damn
it is no be taking it to all over Jimmy
J time getting his run back and he is
now in such a good position in this
group he's undefeated match wise so far
in the pool he's up 2-0 but he's won
every single match four games to zero as
well that is insane Noby what what
they've been doing in Japan mark they've
been training they've been getting ready
he mentioned it in the video as well the
entire world is focused on certain
players and he hopes that he's able to
take it back for Japan that's what it is
man like I feel like you know for him he
says look Pakistan people are
concentrating on them now it used to be
the people who come straight when Japan
and Korea now that hunt that
concentration has shifted and I think he
doesn't really like that is that no you
know what you need to respect Japan and
now he's fighting for not only himself
before his country and that's why we
might be seeing and play so well right
now yeah sometimes you got to fight this
for more than yourself and look at this
know be with a commanding lead here
obviously is only played to match two
but still that's a good position to be
in and right now I mean everybody else
is a playing catch-up right yeah
absolutely and our next match is gonna
be a good one it's one that is very
important as well
we have Janelle going up in his low high
two guys that have lost in a pretty bad
fashion so they need to get a win on the
board this is a very important match
Chanel of course that these guys have
played each other check out there check
out our show the netlink energy
channeling chanela energy that's tight I
like it
type exclamation about joystick in the
chat for the finest gaming peripherals
as you as you saw there by a portion L
guys getting ready getting adjusted but
again shadow sack wampa USA of course
official joystick partner of the Tekken
World Tour the finest boy the finest all
right both of these I mean what do you
think I think we're gonna see the
classic it's gonna be Shaheen versus
ELISA or are we gonna get a surprise are
we gonna see is Safina I think it's
gonna be Shaheen ELISA I mean I have
seen these guys play I think lohi has
been taking it moreover should know but
has always been very close so business
as usual there I believe so I believe so
yeah the fact that he didn't go to
subpoena last much as well kind of makes
me think that he must have robbed at
least for the whole tournament and there
it is yet Shaheen and ELISA is going to
be the match ship arctic snowfall
sometimes you got to believe thank God
for the Machine mm-hmm all right guys
here we go
match number one both of these players
have not gotten a win yet here in group
stage
yeah they definitely do on the board and
it would be good if it was two Oh as
well because every match counts when it
comes to the standings yeah they're
playing catch-up at this point hmm all
right Arctic snowfall low walls but you
don't need that if you're a robot
right if you're realize Habibi either
let's get into it versus ELISA fight
goes for the track move but unfortunate
there got a ton of poke damages because
of the effects nature his ability to
sites that way yeah
he's trying to stay in that closure and
go down low high amounts of the pressure
and he said that he does a lot better at
the at the mid-range so lo hago gonna
wanna give him to a space here we go
runs up to him does down for two this
should be close to death yeah and I
think that move is gonna be key the use
of down for two and of course just kind
of spacing it out in the ways that a lot
of players have been doing with Shaheen
lately that's gonna be key in the match
oh yeah
Milo hockey pan is so simple unsafe
there with the down boardwalks finishes
the round it's on the board all right
Chanel trying to change things up using
the jab in conjunction with that down
port for gold for some of the quicker
folks here we really trying to control
the spacing low high what you gonna do
to deal with it nice punish there yeah
trying to go from the side mix-up but
Chanel's backdashing
too good Elyse has always been known as
the counter with really really good
movement they have you got low tide from
low height yeah we're gonna get the
conversion here goes for the surf can
low high witness much without taking the
cap y'all keep on that's the mark of a
true perfect grip
keep your head on straight I'm talking
to both characters alright nice able to
open them up with the down floor but
again about even unlife for both of
these players someone's gonna have to
take a risk here there's no time left
goes through the ground
I think Aloha has a small small life
lead not anymore
wouldn't watch right when he went for
the down three Chanel ready for it ended
up with the hot kick series and look at
that on the scoreboard yep one rounds
apiece hit in the first game whoa chain
saws were out yeah it wasn't having any
of that he wanted to put those away
straight away
yes good stuff relentless poking here
from below how the change will come out
once again it yeah a nice little low
poke just to put the chainsaws away yeah
I mean both of these players probably
some of the best when it comes to just
getting in your face and using safe
tactics safe pokes limiting in your
opponent's movement limiting their if
their spacing as well it's crazy blower
going for those big fees they were the
hop cake got punished from Chanel avow
luckily all these runs right down to the
wire no head today not today I'm on a
diet
alright follow up here in able to get
the confirmation with the hint and look
at that Chanel on the scoreboard with
two routes to one right now looking to
take that first match Oh range it gets
the grab you had the size that could
have got more from that still don't know
how working nice counter jab into the
instant while rising to this is gonna be
a big damage combo to follow up here
yeah you spoke about Marcus his
reactions are so good oh how sweet
and that's a crazy thing to I mean
obviously it's easy this to see if do
you know it's telegraphed but he pulled
that out of nowhere
and that was the first time you used
that punch in that matchup instantly
ductus well yeah he was ready he knows
the ranges final round basket finally
goes for the slide change without once
again
my stopwatch slide ooh guaranteed hit
that oh man he was out of range arrow
was going for the wasa need to think so
oh he had the right read but it just
didn't connect not go under a hot cake
yeah I mean robots nowadays man
technology Christmas the future is now
yeah all right Jenelle I don't know
there's it's hard to say I think Laura
has a slight lead here not anymore I get
the kick and that's gonna be enough he
should be able to close that as long as
he gets his time on this he does yeah
keeps it simple and low high with the
reverse match a very close match though
you should know nannies to think hard
only never mind he just wanna think
cards straight back in it was a close
match he wants to keep the momentum
going they're going right into the
rematch he's contended with no walls
this I mean wow I don't know man
sometimes it's good to take a breather
right it is yeah but it's funny when I
was like again when I was in Pakistan
like when I wasn't the tournament dead
nobody took a breather
everybody was stories guys are used to
playing as many matches in they can yeah
is the little time is again those guys
are first to 30 monsters oh nice punish
they're right in the gut look up no hard
look at the damage as well that's the
biggest buff that gene got in season 3
it's a damage buff from the compost yeah
all right and he's just very content
again playing it safe double scorpy nice
punish there notice our low highs all so
dashing up into the downpour on to
realign with chanelle's movement it's a
way to keep the size that they made low
heights is looking really really strong
right now he's starting to outpace it's
really start you show here in the
matchup against Rennell yeah he is
winning the exchanges up close he's
winning on the spacing game Chanel's
gonna have to start taking risk I hate
to say it yeah but this Arlo hearts get
warmed up my that's dangerous no hard to
play against as well [ __ ] now he's a
break the momentum right now any time
low high is starting to feel himself and
you start seeing these clutch reads hop
kicks over low stuff like that yeah
that's when he becomes the most
dangerous alright to beat the opps turn
yeah good on it and select bake counter
hit okay do some top it with a get up
kick head counts him from low high yeah
Ben get up kicks a bit the MVP of the
weekend if you have speedy yeah all
right let's see what he does with it he
does have a slight life lead again both
of these players drawn into that
position well it's a full string damn no
rage for low high though just outside of
it literally Oh hot beaches
he was really cheeky with that point
that was great oh the chainsaws alright
cut him up yeah down on the port this is
very close match and again both of these
guys are right at the bottom of the
group as well they need this win so
desperately such an important match for
the standings nice
oh he was able to step it and look at
that Chanel with the lead but all mine
oh nevermind it's too close to call yeah
looks like low highs out in front
Oh big countering again that's the
second time he set him up for that it's
gonna be a big chunk that damaged leaves
low Hyde raised oh she has access to
that fourth you frame raised drive
launch ah yeah if he's able to confirm
it
yeah that's the thing it's a two piece
what's he gonna do here nice good damage
there Chanel one slipper away from
taking this round and going into the
lead here in match number two try to
throw out the razor opposition that was
ready first so here we go trying to even
up the session now one round away
oh he finished it wasn't ready for their
second hit able to get some extra damage
at him but low line fighting back now
yeah playing your block wall
aggressively look at the post Hey
Oh
oh my god I just lost my lunch sometimes
this movement sometimes the art of doing
nothing and second is the scariest thing
it's so cool though right in a game
where you just do nothing and this is so
hot yeah
people are screaming just cuz he's
standing there okay both gods of rage oh
you're able to stop the range Drive and
look at that tied up on rounds and there
you go now you I use low high on set
point to take you 200 over Chanel it's
been a break host set but the two always
all that match to go high right now this
is big I mean if he's able to take it I
mean best position of course would be
able to get two straight matches like
you said yes the law I really need this
one but Chanel with the lead back turn
time go for the tricks yeah back to
shenanigans and again look at this just
solid play overall from low lines poking
away both guys Oh in the red now it's
gonna have to be careful on the low
slide and [ __ ] now is gonna even it up
one match a piece H and X alright so
maybe you want wolves I mean I it's hard
to say for either one of these players
walls can benefit both I mean they both
have a great combo damage but I feel
like the wall carrying the consistency
is probably in Sheen's favorite yeah I
agree I agree
that's what no how I wanted for sure he
went straight to the Mishima dojo no
thinking about it and it's the final
match here so important you have to say
that the loser of this match is prob is
most likely gonna be out man I mean this
is a very bad position but we have seen
good comebacks already today definitely
not over by any means for both of these
guys but you definitely want this win
born
alright starting it off goes for the
full string here going back another way
there big counter it and the follow from
low high yeah a quick start head for low
high trying to keep them out there with
a lock-down board for again going for
that down for two unable to get anything
out of it goes for the throw
yeah he has a lobby now such low I
doesn't mean even taking a big big risks
again Chanel showing why his
sidestepping is one of the best of the
world did you see that side Senate I'm
just trying to get in try try to find
these opportunities and right now
whittling away at low highs life bar
yeah back to the walls gonna have to be
careful stop that [ __ ] no Oh fine that
should be the round yeah let's go up
beyond nice low high low high with the
lead right now this is tough again as we
mentioned either one of these players
have a win yet this is crucial for them
very very crucial especially because
both of them lost 200 as well yeah again
right now counter jabs Chanel starting
use that one too Oh ended up whipping
wanted to get the pick up there on the
whip slide yes I'm fortunate man Chanel
not quick enough know how chilling yeah
he should be I mean don't want to take a
risk goes into the low again yeah
things I was quite happy to take it goes
to the hump being nice punished there
with one one gone chainsaw is now good
block in still have a small lively hair
but his position is to the wall no break
on the throw
yeah go for it and look has them at the
wall and catches that that might be it
oh one puts the head away that down
three should now watching it yeah the
rain thought that down dream one of the
best options he added that in that
opportunity yeah I like it
making sure he has at least at and the
thing is with that on hit police have
the built-in mix up as well he has the
second in as well absolutely
oh oh and you first you don't succeed do
it again try and try again take it to
the wall this is gonna be accurate combo
nevermind
commentators curse then in fact it's one
of those days it's a real thing
all right the follow-up here uses those
down threes and Chanel with the rake
right now has a good opportunity goes
for the drive and the low and see the
thing is you know low light not wanted
to take the wrist not wanting to talk
after that sequence as well yeah he
wants to finish it with a downward one
that's the safest option the head below
high oh he's trying to win punished easy
able to get it the persistence there and
right now low high one round away from
taking the set this is very very
important catching they'll take it to a
final final round
oh now for two it just might happen
rights push you towards the wall here
you guys up at the corner good
positioning here low eyes gonna have to
do something to get out of there Oh put
the brakes on Chanel so close it into a
final round
oh no put the hit cook family down back
to straight doesn't get a big coming
from it luckily fishing now
still in this see what he does with it
again just chop it away mmm
having this opportunity oh you got a
second in in the wall that's the ball is
that it look at this combo oh my god oh
my games oh my days tied up here here we
go final final round who's gonna be I
can't tell it all comes down to this the
news of this might you be
oh and 2 in the bracket and it'll slide
through low high it's a follow up here
of course going for that look at this
leap oh he caught up out of the air
those not gonna do as much damage as you
wanted but it was a nice I just wanted
the combo look at that decent chunk get
okie as well
keeps them there oh my god oh my gosh
Chanel has range available look at the
first now the counter
guaranteed follow-up and lo I able to
take it now unfortunately for Chanel now
oh and to in this in the in the group
yes and no hi keeping his hopes alive
hearing group D of the Tekken World Tour
Finals ladies and lads it is looking
like it's gonna be a fun one no high def
you know out of it man he's been playing
too good to go out this early man all
all throughout the year winning
tournaments he's one master events Rev
major you went down there he said he
only went down there to actually play
oh hey Sonny who's actually in his pool
and they end up winning the tournament
in in Korea for the winning all
tournament making top level Koreans look
like they would just have no business to
be in there with him yeah speaking of a
wife honey as you mentioned he's
actually coming up on stage right now
we're about to see a long awaited
matchup you guys can see the players on
the screen right now it's gonna be USA
vs. Pakistan happiest to play I don't
think they have know they haven't played
before I think Jimmy the only pox on
he's played is our slot right yeah yeah
and he's always talking well versus our
one in one as far as I'm concerned in
yeah tournament play the Invitational
tournaments I think that was the one
before Evo Jimmy you on that one yeah
and you guys can see on the screen right
now Jimmy ended up losing his opening
match here in group stage so he
obviously needs this one to stay in
contention right he is definitely also
in that same position where he needs to
get a win on the board and that would
put him tied with low high as well
actually it would time with with a waist
on the and low high since oh oh and he
would also be one-on-one yeah this is
worrying it's crazy yeah
Jimmy J track
this is someone that you know he goes to
match up he know he knows the matchup
but he also has a lot more knowledge
he's got a message for us on the stream
take it away so competitive Tekken is
kind of like an offset of what I grew up
in I grew up in the arcades and it was a
very competitive scene and recently I
feel like I've lost I've kind of lost
touch with my love of the game and loved
computing so I try to think back to my
earlier beginnings where I would play in
the art cave without any sort of money
or anything just playing for pride and
trying to win I guess the opponent next
to me
that's deep I mean that is deep just
thinking about that sometimes you have
to remember like where you came from how
competition used to be back in the day I
mean yeah you could be at the top of the
world but you always got to think back
what makes you a better player
absolutely man you know he's just trying
to think back what what what made him
have that drive to compete you know
trying to go back and remember back in
the day in the arcades and hopefully
he's found that because he's going up
against a beast right now Oh where's
honey we're gonna see this matchup I
can't wait now look I know arias is
restreaming it over hopefully is
reciever he's probably losing his mind
now you know we've seen from me already
that me chooses to go for Bryant versus
the Akuma matchup he has so many tools
to beat Akuma 3+4 will counter hit the
down tubes they'll keep Akuma out
there's so much damage as well when you
block it down for let's see if Jimmy can
utilize all the tools yeah to keep the
demon at bay let's see what he does
Jimmy J Tran obviously you know he is a
lab monster and he has definitely
studied the tapes instantly I thought
dreamers for such a solid keep at move
County had launched as well yeah and
that's a scary thing too with that 3+4
he's gonna have to watch out because oh
cool what still has options you know he
has the ability to jump he has the focus
attack yes it's not free all banned if
he doesn't get the second 2:38 of that
Wow
into the last 91 and that's the move
which has so much push but I don't even
get punching ice get some decent really
really good damage off of that and Jimmy
he tried taking that first round
very slowly first round that from Jimmy
yeah he had actually a very tough match
opening up against Adobe earlier on
let's see if he's been able to adjust
here might have been cold our West honey
is finding his range item over he's
nothing missing heavy no 5c that is the
classic boys honey we have the whiff
punished here and he gets the damage oh
my gosh away honey standing two on the
money here we go looking for the seven
golden legs there it is and that
launched you don't get that launched an
accident that that was confidence right
there you yes he knew there was gonna be
a duck there he was ready for it he's
gonna be able to push through the wall
this is what what yeah Bronk Bronk moved
that yeah I wasn't sure what he was
known for their had probably tried to go
to the quarter circle four two one
yes causes so much issues for him away
honey how does he can answer back yes
Barbie it's working yeah and that's
where it's dangerous of course Jimmy's
gonna have to be very very careful to
stay out of that range yeah where he can
both use standing - there it is
he's threat threatening the orbital as
well which can go I can go over the down
threes place okay I let me manage to get
combo at big damage and he has an extra
meter as well nice money share from
Jimmy yeah not out of it yet
oh good but yeah we punch the follow up
he had the wall here using the base flat
brilliant I like what I'm seeing here
goes off the bed now with Jimmy with the
rabies he can end it with one hit 0:04
you have to have coffee
do that move final route first game was
gonna take it who was gonna draw first
blood here in this series again using
that down three he's close to having two
meters as well he's that one in a half
right now oh my just goes right on back
punch yeah went slightly with the down
three should be in sight to the wall I
almost got at the bar meter oh he missed
the run III all that could have been bad
you went for the jet upper big way for
the super sore don't punish have you got
another clean hit mark this might be it
if we can find the one it's a small
stage oh he dropped the jab good punish
there from Jimmy what's he gonna do here
he's gonna have to clutch this one out
this is gonna be very difficult my side
step no punishment oh my Brian at the
wall is so scary
one torn back for all he needs but he
managed to get himself out of there
orbital he was out of range here starts
to use the range eyes oh my god all the
sights set that was good
he's surviving for the single pixel
hopper how long has it been
oh he's still getting over SEC oh and he
gets hit with a down for three there Wow
no way honey
Denton's not disappoint yeah oh it's
quite the battle between these two
brilliant players yes definitely know
that Jimmy has his answers for Humabon
away Sonny just one step ahead man
the width punishment as well we have to
mention him I know where Sonny's with
punishment with the kuma is better than
every ones that we've seen with the
Comanche standing to is not a quick move
right it's not a jab he is able to cover
so much ground with that yeah and really
make things happen understand the
spacing as well required rod with all
these shine for always honey
[Applause]
all right starting off here cuz he see
that new eyebrow raised from Jimmy's all
right crowd is getting hype they're
getting excited here we go Pakistan USA
this is the stage shoe this is the say
that Jimmy loves ya let's see how it
works out to find just me
has there been enough data to download
race you guys the rock punish nice I
like that sending to hit the wall here
don't break though doesn't matter oh you
had a big opportunity be there yeah mate
you cancelled you just in time they're
able to get a punish but of course this
is the time where you start taking some
liberties here especially what a Koopa
does not have meter yes absolutely you
have to have a quick stop before he gets
all those resources yeah don't let him
build that meter back 100 he was waiting
for it good space the temperature at the
moment always how you just one step
ahead at the moment
raise your failure booth we've got ever
to use their wares money on the board
second batch yeah why Heidi really
showing his knowledge here the magic as
well not afraid of Brian hello wow look
at these folks
everything is landing here for all my
honey our bodies are named Jimmy out the
wool bouts a West honey will move
quickly onto set point head to take it
over Jimmy to to Oh
he is playing out of his mind he
definitely turned it up he's carrying
the hopes and dreams of a country on his
shoulders right now this is no joke
I wear honey with a combo opportunity
flash in front of what what's gonna do
Jimmy going back the other way
no unfortunately there he hasn't gotten
the right girl oh this is big whoa oh my
God look at the damage
oh my gosh what a combo hey man that
moves baby feel good Oh run punish you
gotta be careful on the orbits down here
we go Jimmy stayin alive here two rounds
to one let's see what happens
the crowd is alive nice blog and a great
punish there hope there's a sick punish
breaks the wall heavy gone nice bus is a
demon pocket cause I'm gonna read a plan
is this enough unfortunate there that
could have been brought down he's
definitely you've raised rice bet he
wants that wolf she's gonna do this is
tough
one for the counter get from unable to
get him in a dive kick and look at that
Oh wisely able to destroy give me two
zero
damn so that now means that Dobie other
ways have you both war and oh it matches
at the top of that leaderboard Jimmy J
Tran losing two matches oh and four damn
Jimmy not having the best start of uh of
this Tekken finals yeah tough I mean
that puts him into a position where he's
now lost two matches yeah I lost too
much as an and that's zero games one as
well it's rough it's rough it's rough
man but ladies and lads
this pool is stacking up to be very very
interesting you definitely don't want to
miss it we're gonna have a short break
and when we return more Group D action
don't go anywhere